- [Gary] I don't think anything
is a good thing or bad thing.
I think you should spend plenty
of time with girlfriend and
I think you should
spend plenty of time
listening to my crap
and getting better.
What you should cut out,
it's all the other stuff
like do you bowl?
Do you play games on your phone?
Are you watching
"House of Cards," "Breaking Bad"
there's other things to cut.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday morning
of your life?
("Holla If Ya Hear Me"
by Kweku Collins)
What up Vayner Nation?
It's me Gary.
Listen, a year ago, ironically,
100 episodes ago I set on the
mission to show you
and document the way I ran
my life as an entrepreneur,
as a businessman,
as a person really.
I really set out to make a video
series that would've inspired me
as a 15, 16, 17-year-old.
I think there's a lot of content
out there that helps people
that learn by tactics.
The reverse of how I learn.
I learned by watching and
pattern recognition and
picking up on vibe.
I didn't need the things that
they taught in school
to become an entrepreneur.
I needed to see somebody
living it, doing it and so as
I pondered what I was going
to do for episode 100
I realized that I didn't
want do anything.
Nothing special, nothing fancy
just a quick little thank you.
Just a quick little
acknowledgment that your
comments mean so much to me.
As some of you have noticed,
I started getting more active in
("Holla If Ya Hear Me"
by Kweku Collins)
I just wanted to say
thanks to all of you.
I hope you've gotten as much out
of this as I've gotten from you
guys in return and
I promise you that
I'll continue to do it.
Continue to bring it.
Sorry for the very basic episode
100, but to be very frank,
it feels super honest and super
real and super to the way
I actually roll so that's
how we're gonna do it.
But wait 'til you
see episode 101.
Oh and one last thing,
what's the number one thing
you've learned from
DailyVee so far?
the YouTube comments and
I will continue to do that.